انا الان انتقلت الى ضاحيه نونتير وتحديدا
الى المكان الذي قتل وصلت
للمراهق نائل كما ترى هناك نعم كما ترى
هناك اشخاص يقومون الان بوضع الزهور
وياتون
لمشاهده هذه المنطقه وهم في حاله حزن
شديده على هذا المراهق الذي استقرت سيارته
هنا حيث ترونها على الصوره ولفظ انفاسه
الاخيره بعدما اطلق شرطي النار عليه هناك
كما ترون عدد كبير من اللافتات التي
مكتوبه ايضا احدى اللافتات تقول كم نائل
لم يتم تصوير حادثه مقتله كما نعلم حادثه
نائل تم تصويرها وتوثيقها بالكامل وهي
السبب التي الذي فجر كل هذا العنف كان
هناك
الاشخاص الذين ص وروا هذه الحادثه ويقومون
الان بالتظاهرات وكل اعمال العنفذه يقولون
ان كل شيء واضح ولهذا السبب هم يقومون
بهذه الاعمال هذه سيده ربما ايضا
تضع صوره احد الاشخاص على
التيشيرت الذي ترتديه ربما هو ايضا احد
ضحايا عنف الشرطه مكتوب على هذه
التيشيرت العداله من اجل كريسكابا
تقول تقول هذه السيده انهم من عائله الشاب
كريسكابا الذي قتل على يد عناصر الشرطه
العام الماضي هم جاؤوا الى هنا
[موسيقى]
مغني الراب تقول تقول السيده
نعم تقول السيده انهم جاؤوا الى هنا لدعم
عائله نائل لان ما حدث مع نائل حدث مع
ابنهم سابقا
ولهذا هم يدعمون العائله وقاموا بالوصول
الى هذه المنطقه نايف هناك ايضا روايه
جديده صدرت على
تطبيق سناب شات وهي روايه الشخص الثالث او
المراهق الثالث الذي كان مع نائل في
السياره عندما تعرض للقتل في ذلك اليوم
كانوا ثلاثه اشخاص ثلاثه اصدقاء نائل الذي
قتل برصاص الشرطه وكان
بجانبه شخص اخر اعتقلته الشرطه لكن الشخص
الثالث تمكن من الفرار من السياره ونشر
فيديو على على تطبيق سناب شات روى فيه
الحادثه وقال ان عناصر الشرطه عندما
لاحقوهم اوقف نائل سيارته للمره الاولى
وقاموا بركل باب السياره طلبوا من نائل ان
ينزل زجاج السياره لكي يتحدثوا معه
[موسيقى]
الذي قتل هل ذكر لماذا لم يستجيبوا لداءات
الشرطه بالتوقف بانزال الزجاج يعني لماذا
هم بالهرب قبل ان يقتل
الشاب الذي نشر هذا المقطع على سناب شات
قال انهم ان نائل امتثل لاوامر الشرطه
وقام بانزال زجاج السياره وتحدث مع الشرطه
لكن هنا بدا عناصر الشرطه بركل باب
السياره يطلبون منه اطفاء المحرك وكانوا
يهددونه بانهم سوف يطلقون النار لذلك شعر
بالخوف فسارى وصل المسير بالسياره لكنه لم
يسر مسافه بعيده جدا سنحاول ان نعرض عليكم
المنطقه التي كانت فيها السياره اذا كان
بالامكان الذي ترونه الان
الشارع وقفت السياره وقفت سياره نقل عندما
كانت هنا الاشاره المروريه حمراء وكان
هناك ازدحام لم يتمكن نائل من الاستمرار
في
التقدم بسيارته وهنا وصل اليه عناصر
الشرطه ايضا طالبوه باطفاء المحرك وبداوا
بركل باب السياره بحسب روايه صديقه كان
الشباك مفتوح وهو كان يتحدث مع عناصر
الشرطه لكنه لم يمتثل لاوامرهم باطفاء
المحرك وبالتالي عندما فتحت الاشاره حاول
التقدم قليلا لكن هنا كان الشرطي قد اطلق
الرصاص عليه بحسب روايه صديقه وفي هذه
النقطه توقفت السياره عندما لم يسيطر
عليها نائل وكان فاقدا للوعي بعدما تلقى
الرصاصه توقفت هنا في هذه المنطقه وكان
هناك صور بثتها العربيه للسياره ولفظوا
لفظ انفاسه الاخيره هنا كما ترى هناك ظهور
كثيره وضعت هنا وعبارات كثيره كتبت هذه
احدى العبارات مكتوب عليها السلام لروحي
نائل لتكن الارض حنونه عليك ايضا هناك
عبارات اخرى كما ذكرت قبل قليل هذه
اللافته الكبيره مكتوب عليها كم من نائل
لم يتم تصويره في اشاره الى ان حادثه مقتل
الشاب نائل تم تصويرها بالكامل من احدى
السكان الذين يقطنون في هذه البنايه التي
كان احد الاشخاص اول سكان يوثق الحادثه
منذ لحظه ايقاف سياره نائل واطلاق الشرطي
النار عليه طيب لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات